how do you like a behind-the-scenes look
and one of nature's most luxurious
full-service hippo spas our dominant
male hippo customer has already arrived
here at the mazuma spring in Kenya
Africa the carp goes right to work it
uses its wide rasping mouth to scour the
hippos hi
the hippo gets vici clean skin and fish
gets a rich buffet dead skin algae and
parasites
how about that tail that looks kind of
like a toilet brush the cichlid fish
takes care of that how about no how can
I say this discretely the hippos
hindquarters where the hippo produces
hippo duck the barbel fish eagerly dives
in here especially when the hippo is in
done production mode the barbel is so
eager for what the hippo is trying to
get rid of that they race after him like
an autograph seekers chasing a rock star
finally the hippo opens its mouth
Homa the good stuff and the fish rush in
like hungry shoppers at a half-off bake
sale
what the hippo has enjoyed the full
treatment and after it's done enjoys a
relaxing yarn of relief